hi in this module i'm going to introduce
the forward backward algorithm for
performing exact and efficient inference
and hidden markov models which are an
important special case of bayesian
networks
so let's revisit our object tracking
example now through the lens of hidemak
recall that at each time i
there's an object that is at a position
particular position h i
object might have gone
this trajectory
in each position there's also a noisy
observation
0
2 and 2.
so let's formally define
a probabilistic story for how this
these data might occur
so we start at
h1 which is the position of object at
time step one
and we're going to generate this
position
uniformly at random
probably one third one third one third
for each of these possible positions
zero one or two
and then i'm going to transition into
the second time step so in general i'm
going to look at h i minus 1
look into each i which is going to be
up with
probability of one quarter the same with
probably one half and
down with probably one half
so mathematically this looks like this
um h i can be h i minus one minus one
the same plus one
probabilities
so this transition distribution is also
used to generate h3 given h2
now at each time step i have an emission
of e1 e2 and e3
and in general i'm looking at the actual
position
at time step i
and i'm going to generate e i according
to essentially the same process which is
up with probability one quarter
same with probability one half and down
with probably one
and this is
local conditional distribution formally
stated
now i
multiply
all the trend of the colloquial
conditional distributions together
we have the probability of start h1 we
have the probability of
each i given h i minus 1 for each
subsequent time step
times the probability of
the noisy sensor reading e i given the
actual position h i for all the time
steps
and this gives us the joint distribution
for all over all the actual positions
and sensor readings
so now let's ask questions about our
data markov
so there's two types of questions which
are common
one is called filtering
and the other is called smoothing so the
filtering question
is something like this which is i'm
interested in a particular
object
location at a particular time step h2
given some evidence
which is all the sensor readings that
i've seen
before that
smoothing
is similar except for i in addition
condition on the future
so i might observe e3
is equal to 2 as well
so notice that filtering is actually a
special case of smoothing if we
marginalize unobserved leaves
so uh to show this suppose we have um
just this
network or hmm
and i didn't observe e3
if i didn't observe e3 e3 is just on
observed leave
and i can marginalize it out by
just removing it
now h3 is an observed leaf and i can
remove that as well
so now this filtering query
is actually a smoothing query where
there is no future because i don't
observe the future
so
now let us just focus on
smoothing queries
without loss of generality
so the forward backward algorithm is
based on dynamic programming and the key
uh idea is to represent
the set of all assignments using
allowance
so this lattice is a directly acyclic
graph not to be confused with actual
hmm or pigeon network
there's a start state
and an end state
and
each
column is going to represent a
particular value
and each row is going to correspond to
a particular variable
so and each path
through
this lattice
now is going to correspond to
an assignment
of
values to all the variables for example
if i go through this path and set h1
equals 0
h2 equals 2 and h3 1.
so this is just a very compact way of
representing all exponentially many
assignments in a
in a polynomial sized object
so now i'm going to attach weights to
the edges
so
edge start to any of these initial
states has weight
the start probability times
the first emission probability
for example this edge here has weight
h probability of h1 equals zero
times probability of e1 equals zero
given h1
because e1 remember was observed to be
zero so i've plugged in that evidence
so now the subsequent edges are between
some h i minus 1 and some h i
and that has weight the transition
probability times the emission
probability of the destination
state
for example this edge here has
a
weight
probability of h2 equals zero
uh given h1 equals zero that's the
transition times probability of e2
equals two
which is what we observe as evidence
condition on h2 equal
and this one is h3 equals zero given h2
equals zero times the emission
probability and this edge doesn't have
anything on it so
assume it to be one
[Music]
and now
each path
as we stated before
from start to end
is an
assignment of
of all the variables
but in particular it has weight that's
equal to
the product of the edge weights
so this path here
has weight which is simply the product
of all these purple numbers
okay so and that weight is actually the
joint probability of
this particular assignment and the
evidence
okay so now the key part
is
that smoothing queries such as
probability of h i given
e i
e equals e
is simply the weighted fraction of paths
through
h i equals h i
so for example if i'm looking interested
in what is the probability
of h2 equals one condition on evidence
what i'm really asking in the context of
this lattice is
what is the fraction
of paths that pass through this node
compared to all paths
so stated differently
i'm going to look at all the paths
through this
this node
add up all the weights
and divide by
the sum of the weights over all paths
so this gives us a really nice graphical
interpretation of these smoothing
queries
so now we can compute
those quantities
using a recurrence
i'm going to define two
types of objects four word messages and
backward messages
here's our lattice
the forward message
for each
node here is going to be f of i
written
of h of i
and this is supposed to be the sum of
weights of paths from the start to a
particular hi equals hi
so for example
f
2 of
of 1
is going to be
the sum of the weights of all paths
from start to h2 equals
and i can compute this recursively as
follows so all paths that go from here
to here have to
and uh
have to have a previous
position which is one of these so i'm
gonna sum over all possible h i minus 1
values of the previous
variable
and then i'm going to recurse on f i
minus 1 of h
i minus 1 so the sum of all the
weights to each of these previous
locations
times
the weight
of
along the edge from a particular h
i minus 1 to h i
so the backward message is analogous so
b i
of h i
is going to be the sum of weights of all
paths from a particular hi equals hi to
the end
so b2 of 1 is the sum of all paths from
this
to the end
and this again is recursively defined as
looking at all
next nodes
h i plus one
um
and recurse on b of i plus one of h i
plus one
times
the weight
of the edge from between the h i and h i
plus one
okay so now having defined forward and
backward
messages
i can multiply them together
to form s i and my claim is that the sum
of the weights of all paths from start
to end that go through a particular
node is exactly
si of h i
okay so
for example if i'm looking at this node
again
f i is looking at all the ways to go
from start to this node
and then the bi is looking at all the
ways to go from this node to the end
and if i multiply all those
two quantities together then i get
all the paths from start that go through
this node to the
so
now we're almost done
we can take
these sis
and then we normalize them
over all possible other values that each
i could take
and that gives us exactly the
probability of h i equals h i given
the evidence
and this is exactly this the smoothing
uh quantity that we're looking for
what is the probability of h2 equals one
condition on evidence
now putting things together the forward
backward algorithm is going to simply
compute
all the forward messages proceeding from
one to two to three all the way up to n
where f i depends on f i minus one so
i'm going forward
then it's going to compute all the
backward messages going from n down to
one because bi depends on bi plus one
now i'm going to multiply everything to
the fi and the bi together to compute s
i
and normalize and that gives me
the answer to the smoothing question
so the runtime of this algorithm is
so we have n time steps
and for each of the time steps i have
number of domain
elements that i need to consider so this
is the number of
nodes in this lattice
and i have also another multiplicative
factor of domain
because to compute the recurrence
and this is exactly actually the number
of edges
in this lattice
so one other note is that
notice that the four backward algorithm
actually computes all the smoothing
queries for each
i
and this takes time
the time complexity for computing all of
them is exactly the same as computing
uh the one for any individual one
and that's because there's a lot of
shared computation
so the forward message here that's
computed is used down here and here and
same with the backward messages in the
other direction
so let's look at a quick demo of um
this in action so
um here is the
object tracking hmm so we have h1h3
and we
have uh the various probabilities of h1
1 given h1 h2 given h1
e2 h3
so on
and now i'm interested in the
probability
of
h2
so here
notice that i'm actually
not going to
run forward backward but i'm going to
run this more general algorithm called
sum variable elimination
um so the details are going to be a
little bit different so don't worry
about it too much but i just want to
give you a flavor of how it works
so here the
uh the first thing i do is i compute
um this this factor which is actually
the forward
message where i've sum
out
the previous
time step on h1
and then i'm going to compute another
factor which is summing out
the backward message which sums out
h3
and then i'm going to multiply them
together
and i get the probability of h2
to be
0.61
and 0.3
all right so to summarize we've
presented the forward backward algorithm
for proficiency inference in hmms in
particular answering
smoothing questions
so the key idea behind the forward
background is this lattice
representations which allows us to
compactly
represent
paths as assignments
and the weights of each assignment to be
the product of the edge weights
that allows us to define
a dynamic program
which computes the forward and backward
messages
an efficient way
and now if you multiply the forward and
backward messages and normalize now you
can compute all the smoothing queries
you want
um in the same amount of time as
computing any one of them because
there's a lot of shared computation
all right that's the end